este protón en el etanol tiene un valor
de pesca
de aproximadamente 16 mientras que este
protón en el ácido carboxílicos tiene un
valor de pesca
de aproximadamente 5 recuerden entre más
pequeño es el valor de pk
más ácido es el protón entonces por el
valor más bajo de pk y el ácido
carboxílicos es más ácido que el etanol
y podemos explicar esto con las bases
con jugadas si el etanol dona este
protón los electrones en este enlace se
quedarán con el oxígeno dibujemos la
base con jugada
de oxígeno ahora tiene tres pares de
electrones libres y uno de esos pares
corresponde a los electrones en rosa lo
que le da al oxígeno una carga formal
negativa ahora dibujemos la base
conjugada para el ácido carboxílicos
sidón a este protón entonces los
electrones en rosa se quedarán con el
oxígeno así que en la base conjugada
tenemos un carbono unido con un doble
enlace a este oxígeno con dos pares de
electrones libres y del lado derecho
tenemos otro oxígeno con tres pares de
electrones libres uno de los pares
corresponde a los electrones en rosa
esto le da al oxígeno una carga formal
negativa
ahora comparemos nuestras bases con
jugadas las dos tienen una carga forma
negativa en un oxígeno así que debe
existir algún otro factor que estabilice
a una base con jugada ese factor es la
resonancia para la base con jugada de la
derecha podemos tomar estos electrones
en rosa y moverlos hacia acá empujando
estos electrones hacia el oxígeno
dibujemos la estructura de resonancia
ahora tenemos este oxígeno con tres
pares de electrones libres lo que le da
una carga formal negativa y ahora este
oxígeno sólo tiene dos pares de
electrones libres los electrones en rosa
se movieron hacia acá
estos electrones en azul se movieron a
este oxígeno entonces esta carga
negativa se encuentra deslocalizada
recuerden las estructuras de resonancia
no son perfectas en la realidad tenemos
un híbrido de estas dos estructuras así
que la carga negativa está deslocalizada
en dos oxígenos cuando eso ocurre se da
un efecto estabilizador para el año
entonces nuestra base conjugada se
estabiliza por resonancia eso significa
que es más fácil que el ácido
carboxílicos donde este protón es por
eso que vemos un valor bajo de pk
si comparamos esto con la base conjugada
del etanol es decir con el año tóxico no
podemos dibujar una estructura de
resonancia porque no podemos
deslocalizar la carga negativa
esta carga negativa está detenida en
este oxígeno lo que significa que esta
base conjugada no es tan estable no se
puede estabilizar por resonancia así que
el etanol no donará su protón tan
fácilmente y por eso tenemos un valor
más alto de pk
para el etanol entonces para saber cuál
es el protón más ácido hay que dibujar
la base conjugada y su resonancia
aquí tenemos un compuesto orgánico y
nuestro objetivo es determinar cuál es
el protón más ácido será este protón o
este protón digamos que una base entra y
toma este protón de arriba así que los
electrones en este enlace se quedarán en
este carbono rosa dibujemos la base
conjugada tenemos nuestro anillo y este
carbono está unido con un doble enlace a
un oxígeno que tiene dos pares de
electrones libres y los electrones en
rosa se quedaron en este carbón lo que
le da al carbono una carga formal
negativa no olviden que el carbono en
rosa también está unido a otro hidrógeno
pero no lo dibujaré en la base conjugada
ahora digamos que una base entra y toma
este protón eso significa que los
electrones en morado se quedarán en este
carbón dibujemos la base conjugada para
este caso
aquí tenemos este oxígeno con dos pares
de electrones libres los electrones en
color morado se quedaron en este carbón
lo que le da al carbono una carga formal
negativa de nuevo recuerden que este
carbono también está unido a otro
hidrógeno ahora cuál de las dos bases
conjugadas es más estable bueno la base
conjugada de arriba se puede estabilizar
por resonancia podemos tomar estos
electrones en rosa y moverlos para
formar un doble enlace empujando estos
electrones hacia el óxido
vamos a dibujarlo tenemos nuestro anillo
con un doble enlace justo aquí y por acá
tenemos un oxígeno con tres pares de
electrones libres lo que le da una carga
formal negativa así que los electrones
en rosa se movieron hacia acá y estos
electrones en azul se movieron al
oxígeno ahora recuerden que el oxígeno
es más electro negativo que el carbono
soporta mejor una carga negativa
entonces esta estructura de resonancia
de la derecha contribuye más en el
híbrido de resonancia esta base
conjugada se estabiliza por resonancia a
diferencia de esta base conjugada porque
aquí tenemos una carga negativa en este
carbono y no podemos dibujar ningún
estructura de resonancia eso significa
que está base con jugada no es tan
estable como la que tenemos arriba así
que hemos encontrado la respuesta el
protón más ácido es aquel que tiene una
base conjugada que se puede estabilizar
por resonancia este protón que está
unido al carbono que se encuentra junto
a este carbono que está unido con un
doble enlace a este oxígeno este protón
es el protón más ácido y esto es algo
que veremos más adelante porque es muy
importante que lo entiendan